THANK YOU FOR THE MEDICAL UPDATE
TONIGHT.
DR. OZ COMING UP LATER WITH
OTHER DEVELOPMENTS.
ALSO, SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY,
STATE OF LOUISIANA, ONE OF THE
HARDEST HIT BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
SENATOR KENNEDY JOINS US NOW.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS WITH
THE PEOPLE OF THE GREAT STATE
LOUISIANA.
WHY DO WE HAVE MARDI GRAS NUMBER
ONE AND ANOTHER PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HIS BUILDING TRIAGE
HOSPITALS THERE AND SENDING ALL
THE SUPPLIES THERE, WHAT’S THE
STATUS OF THINGS IN LOUISIANA?
>> LIKE MOST STATES, SEAN, WE
ARE CATCHING FRESH HAIL.
I DON’T KNOW WHY BAD THINGS
HAPPEN TO GOOD PEOPLE.
IF I MAKE IT TO HAPPEN -- HAVE
AND I’M GOING TO ASK.
WHERE COPING THANKS PRIMARILY TO
OUR HEROES IN SCRUBS.
WITH THAT THE BEST DOCTORS AND
THE BEST NURSES IN THE BEST
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS IN THE
UNIVERSE.
OUR BIGGEST WORRY -- MY BIGGEST
WORRY, AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
SHARE IT, AMONG MANY WORRIES,
ISN’T VENTILATORS.
WE HAVE, COUNTING THE
VENTILATORS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
SENT TO US, WE HAVE ABOUT 1500.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE 507 OF OUR
PEOPLE AND VENTILATORS AND YOU
SAY, WELL, YOU’VE STILL GOT
TWO-THIRDS OF CAPACITY.
YES, BUT WE JUST DON’T KNOW
WHERE THIS THING IS GOING.
WE JUST DON’T KNOW WHEN WE’RE
GOING TO HIT THE APEX AND START
DOWN THE OTHER SIDE OF THE HILL,
SO THAT’S MY BIGGEST WORRY RIGHT
NOW.
>> Sean: ARE YOU IN CONTACT
WITH THE PRESIDENT?
>> YES.
I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE TOGETHER IN HIS OFFICE
YESTERDAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE SITUATION IN
LOUISIANA.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
INCLUDING THE GAS INDUSTRY.
THE SMALL BUSINESS LOAN PROGRAM
THAT WE PASSED IN OUR CARES ACT
THANKS TO SECRETARY MNUCHIN IS
GOING TO START AND MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT.
MNUCHIN IS SENDING OUT TRACKS
THROUGH THE IRS NEXT WEEK.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE I THINK IT’S
SETTING UP ITS FACILITY TO
LOAN -- THEY ARE NOT BAILOUTS,
THEY ARE LOANS TO LARGE
BUSINESSES.
I’M VERY WORRIED ABOUT OUR STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
PROGRAMS.
I’M REALLY WORRIED THAT -- IT’S
NOT ANYBODY’S FAULT.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY THERE IS
FAULT.
PICKLE HANDLE VOLUME.
>> Sean: DEMOCRATS DIDN’T HAVE
TO PUSH FOR THE KENNEDY CENTER,
NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE ARTS,
HUMANITIES AND DELAY ALL THE
AID, IT WOULD BE GETTING THERE
SOONER.
WE ARE PRAYING FOR YOUR STATE.
WHATEVER YOU NEED, ANYTHING WE